Ich arbeite derzeit an ein paar
neuen Strategien zur Verteidigung des
Kompatibilismus und heute Abend werde
ich eine dieser Strategien vorstellen,
und ich dachte, es wäre eine gute Idee,
diese Strategie kurz zu skizzieren, bevor
ich mit meiner Präsentation so typisch beginne
in kompatibilistisch argumentieren Sie ungefähr wie
folgt Angenommen, ich muss mich zum
Beispiel zwischen heiraten und nicht heiraten entscheiden,
wenn der Determinismus wahr ist, ist meine
Zukunftsentscheidung von der Vergangenheit des
Verlusts abhängig, aber niemand kann etwas
gegen die Vergangenheit tun und niemand kann
etwas tun  Über den Verlust scheint es also, dass
ich nichts für meine zukünftige Entscheidung tun kann,
und die Strategie, die
ich heute Abend vorstellen möchte, besteht aus
drei Schritten als ersten Schritt, und das ist
nichts Neues.
Ich denke, dass Kompatibilist darauf hinweisen
sollte  Argumentation ist, wie ich gesagt habe,
genau genommen ein Fehlschlag, und zwar aus dem
einfachen Grund, weil Folgerung eine
Beziehung zwischen Aussagen ist und nicht
zwischen Entitäten wie der Vergangenheit oder der
Verlust oder meine Zukunftsentscheidung, so streng
genommen und unvereinbar, müßte wohl
wie folgt argumentieren, wenn wir p0 eine
Aussage seien, die die Vergangenheit beschreibt, und
wenn wir L eine Aussage seien,
die den Verlust beschreibt, und wenn wir P eine
Aussage seien, die beschreibt  meine Zukunftsentscheidung
dann, wenn der Determinismus wahr ist, wird P
durch p0 und L impliziert. niemand
kann etwas gegen p0 tun, denn niemand
kann etwas gegen die
Aussage tun, die die Vergangenheit beschreibt
dass
ich an meiner Zukunftsentscheidung nichts ändern kann
, also kommt hier der zweite
Schritt meiner Strategie. Ich denke, Kompatibilität
sollte darauf hinweisen,
dass es nicht immer stimmt, dass
niemand etwas gegen die
Beschreibung der Vergangenheit tun kann, weil es
so ist  Vergangenheitsbeschreibungen,
die zumindest teilweise auch von der Zukunft handeln,
und so müssen unvereinbare Listen
ihre Argumentation neu formulieren und
sagen, naja, keiner kann
was  g Über p04 kann niemand
etwas gegen eine Aussage tun,
die nur die Vergangenheit beschreibt, und niemand
kann aus einem ähnlichen Grund etwas gegen L tun,
also scheint es, dass ich
nichts gegen meine zukünftige Entscheidung tun kann,
und das bringt mich zu  Der dritte und letzte
Punkt meiner Kompatibilitätsstrategie
sollte argumentieren, dass p0 keine
Aussage ist, die nur die Vergangenheit beschreibt,
und das ist im Grunde das, was
ich heute Abend versuche. Ich versuche,
ihnen Argumente für die Schlussfolgerung zu konstruieren, dass
p0 keine ist  satz ausschließlich über die
vergangenheit oder ein satz, der
nur die vergangenheit beschreibt, so ist das der plan für
diesen abend.
wir werden uns zweifellos alle mit
peter van inwagen
in seinem bahnbrechenden buch ein essay über den
freien willen sowie in dieser neuen
sammlung von essays auseinandersetzen  über we
will van inwagen hat mit
beispielloser Strenge und Klarheit eine Vielzahl
von Rahmenbedingungen entwickelt, um das
Problem des freien Willens und des Determinismus anzugehen. Seine
Arbeit hat nicht nur zu einer Wiederbelebung von geführt
inkompatible ISM Seine Arbeit
hat die Art und Weise, wie alle
Teilnehmer des Tages der Debatte
heutzutage über das Problem denken, nachhaltig beeinflusst, so dass
zumindest meiner Meinung nach ein
Essay über die Willensfreiheit und seine Überlegungen
zur Willensfreiheit zu den
wichtigsten und faszinierendsten gehören  Beiträge
, die jemals auf dem Gebiet geleistet wurden,
im Kern eines unveränderlichen Denkens
über den freien Willen
liegt sein wiederholtes Beharren auf der Tatsache,
dass der freie Wille ein Mysterium ist. Er beschreibt
diese Position wie folgt. Ich zitiere, und wir
haben das bereits gehört, wenn wir so wollen  ein
Mysterium, denn es gibt gute Argumente
für die Unvereinbarkeit von Wir wollen und
Determinismus und gute Argumente für die
Unvereinbarkeit von Wir wollen und
Unbestimmtheit, und niemand hat
jemals einen sehr plausiblen Kandidaten
für den Fehler in einem der Argumente in
beiden Klassen gefunden  Natürlich
glaubt, dass das Argument, das ihm
für die Unvereinbarkeit von Willensfreiheit und
Determinismus vorgebracht wird, keine Mängel enthält. Lassen Sie uns
das Zitat machen  und dass es einen Fehler
oder einige Fehler in den bekannten Argumenten
für die Unvereinbarkeit von freiem Willen und
Unbestimmtheit gibt,
aber was die letztere Klasse von Argumenten
betrifft, hat er gut gestempelt, wenn er weiß, was die
Fehler darin sein könnten, hat er einfach
kein Zitat  hat keine Ahnung und zitiert unendliche
Unbestimmtheit Ansicht freier Wille ist ein Mysterium,
weil dies ein weiteres Zitat ist das
Folgende ist sicherlich der Fall, einige
Behauptungen oder vielleicht gibt es mehr als
eine über Angelegenheiten im Zusammenhang mit dem
Determinismus der Willensfreiheit und der moralischen Verantwortung
, die uns scheinen  Offensichtlich wahr sein ist
falsch und zitieren im Folgenden werde ich darauf
hinweisen, was meiner Ansicht nach ein
Spaßfehler in verschiedenen Argumenten für die
Unvereinbarkeit von Wir-Wollen und
Determinismus nach van Inwagen sein könnte.
Nein kann etwas gegen die Wahrheit
von a tun  vollständige Beschreibung eines vergangenen
Zustands der Welt. Meiner Ansicht nach ist dies eine
Aussage über Angelegenheiten im Zusammenhang mit dem
Determinismus des freien Willens und der moralischen
Verantwortung, die jedoch durchaus falsch
sein könnte  es scheint uns
offensichtlich wahr zu sein, aber ich werde nicht
direkt gegen diese
Behauptung argumentieren, sondern ich werde nur argumentieren, dass Fan-in-
Wagen uns keinen Grund gegeben hat zu glauben,
dass diese Behauptung wahr ist, zu diesem
Zweck werde ich drei Argumente entwickeln, aber nicht unterstützen
dass, wenn er erfolgreich ist,
zeigen wird, dass van in Wangs Versuch,
für diesen Satz zu argumentieren, fehlschlägt, werde ich argumentieren,
dass fan in Wangs Versuch, für diesen Satz zu argumentieren,
erstens unvereinbar ist
mit einer Theorie von Sätzen,
nach der notwendigerweise äquivalente
Sätze identisch sind, zweitens
unvereinbar mit einer Beschreibung
Eigennamentheorie, nach der
Eigennamen
Emelia Abkürzungen für eindeutige
Bezeichnungen sind und drittens unvereinbar mit
einer metaphysischen Theorie, nach der
es keine Vergangenheit gibt
Am Ende meines Vortrags skizzierte ich ein
eigenständiges Argument zu dem Schluss,
dass man ihn einlud  Um seine entscheidende Annahmephase zu rechtfertigen,
werde ich zu dem Schluss kommen,
dass es Grund zum Ausdünnen gibt  k dieser Spaß
in Vegas gab uns keinen Grund zu der Annahme,
dass niemand in der Lage ist, etwas gegen
eine vollständige Beschreibung eines vergangenen
Zustands der Welt zu unternehmen. Als Folge davon werde ich zeigen,
dass meine Argumente nicht nur für
Argumente für die
Unvereinbarkeit von Fanbeschwörungen gelten  freier Wille und
Determinismus, aber auch zu einem berühmten
Argument für die Unvereinbarkeit von freiem
Willen und göttlichem Vorherwissen fand ich
diese Parallele in
vielerlei Hinsicht aufschlussreich und so entschied ich mich, mein Argument zu erweitern
, okay, also Naik, also komme ich jetzt
zum zweiten erbärmlichen Punkt
Sie können feststellen, dass es auf
dem Handout zu Beginn hilfreich sein
könnte, die Hauptidee
eines ungültigen Konsequenz-Arguments zu rekapitulieren, um es kurz zu machen.
Lassen Sie uns sagen, dass die
Wahrheit unantastbar ist, nur
weil niemand ist oder jemals war
nichts an ihrer Wahrheit ausrichten
können, wenn wir p0 einen Satz nennen, der den
Zustand der Welt in ferner Vergangenheit ausdrückt,
und wenn wir L die Verbindung
aller Naturgesetze sind  dann
scheint die Hauptidee seines Arguments die folgende zu sein,
angenommen zum Beispiel, dass es wahr ist, dass
ap monedas bei der
Versammlung der Versammlung lügen wird, wenn der
Determinismus wahr ist, die Behauptung, dass, wenn die
Annehmlichkeiten bei der Versammlung der Versammlung lügen werden
Die Zusammensetzung folgt aus der
Konjunktion von p0 und L, aber niemand
kann etwas gegen p0 tun, denn
niemand kann etwas gegen eine
Beschreibung der Vergangenheit
tun, und niemand kann etwas gegen l4 tun, niemand
kann etwas gegen die Gesetze von tun
Naturgemäß folgt daraus, dass wenn der Determinismus
wahr ist, niemand etwas dagegen tun kann
, dass man, wenn man hauptsächlich
in der Versammlung bekanntlich lügt,
ein Parallelargument für die
Unvereinbarkeit von freiem Willen und göttlichem
Vorwissen konstruieren könnte  und es ist
in dieser Hinsicht nicht verwunderlich, dass für eine nur ungültige
Verteidigung die Ansicht, dass wir wollen und der
Determinismus unvereinbar sind, aber auch
die Ansicht, dass wir vorher wissen und
vorhersagen werden  ge sind unvereinbar, denn
denken Sie noch einmal über die Aussage nach, dass
wir bei Bedarf bei der
Versammlung der Versammlung lügen werden, wenn wir p0
die Aussage sein lassen, an die Gott lange
vor der Existenz des ersten Menschen geglaubt hat, die p
Hauptführer a erzählen werden
bei der Versammlung der Versammlung lügen, dann
scheint die Hauptidee des Arguments
die folgende zu sein, nehmen Sie erneut an, dass
es wahr ist, dass, wenn er uns brauchen wird,
bei der Versammlung der Versammlung eine Lüge erzählt wird, wenn
dies der Vorschlag ist, dass die Hauptführer der Abgeordneten dies tun
werden  bei der versammlung eine lüge erzählen
folgt aus p0 aber niemand
kann was gegen p0 denn
niemand kann was gegen die
beschreibung der vergangenheit daraus folgt dass
niemand nicht mal
amina das kann da was machen  wenn er
bei der Versammlung der Versammlung bedeutungslos lügen wird,
so war das nur,
um das Argument zu rekapitulieren, also komme ich jetzt
zum dritten Punkt, der Starrheit von
Beschreibungen der Vergangenheit,
die ich im Folgenden identifizieren werde  Was
meiner Ansicht nach ein Fehler in beiden
Argumenten sein könnte, werde ich versuchen zu zeigen, dass der
Versuch, die Annahme zu rechtfertigen,
dass p0 eine unantastbare Wahrheit ist, fehlschlägt
und dass er uns daher keinen
Grund gegeben hat zu glauben, dass p0 eine
unantastbare Wahrheit ist, ja  und außerdem
werde ich zeigen, dass meine Argumentation
nicht nur für das Argument für
die Unvereinbarkeit von Wir-Wollen und
Determinismus gilt, sondern auch für das Argument für
göttlichem Vorherwissen, also komme ich jetzt zu
drei Punkt 1 - in Van  rechtfertigt diese
Annahme und dort finden Sie das
Zitat hier Jedenfalls findet sich in Tüten
Versuch, diese Annahme zu rechtfertigen Zitat
p0 ist offensichtlich eine unantastbare Wahrheit p0
ist eine unantastbare Wahrheit aus dem gleichen
Grund, aus dem Dinosaurier einst auf der Erde wandelten,
ist beides eine unantastbare Wahrheit  Unsere
Wahrheiten über die Vergangenheit und tatsächlich die Wahrheit
über die vormenschliche Vergangenheit und der Hafen an
anderer Stelle halten den Fan in Wagen fest, dass
kein Agent in der Lage ist, eine wahre Behauptung falsch zu machen
Bevor ich erkläre, warum ich Zweifel an
diesem Argument habe, werde ich zunächst versuchen,
die Argumentation der Bank zu rekonstruieren. Auf den
ersten Blick scheint er wie folgt zu argumentieren,
und Sie finden alle
Rekonstruktionen auf dem Handout, sodass die
erste Rekonstruktion p0 ist  eine wahre
Aussage über die Vergangenheit zweite
Prämisse jede wahre Aussage über die
Vergangenheit ist eine unantastbare Wahrheit, daher ist
p0 eine unantastbare Wahrheit, aber es ist
einfach nicht wahr, dass jede wahre
Aussage über die Vergangenheit eine
unantastbare Wahrheit ist, denn wie
aus Debatten über den freien Willen bekannt ist  und göttliches
vorauswissen es gibt sätze
über die vergangenheit die sich nicht ausschließlich
auf die vergangenheit beziehen zb der
satz dass ich gestern
das letzte mal geraucht habe ohne zweifel das ist ein
satz über die vergangenheit er sagt
etwas über die vergangenheit aus nämlich dass
ich gestern trotzdem geraucht habe  Bei diesem
Satz geht es nicht nur um das,
denn er sagt etwas über die Zukunft aus,
nämlich dass ich werde  nie
wieder rauchen und nun annehmen, dass ich gestern
tatsächlich zum letzten Mal geraucht habe, dann scheint die
Aussage, dass ich gestern zum
letzten Mal geraucht habe, eine wahre
Aussage über die Vergangenheit zu sein, die
keine unantastbare Wahrheit ist, denn selbst wenn ich
nie wieder rauchen werde  Ich kann
zweifellos wieder rauchen und kann
daher etwas dagegen tun, dass
ich gestern zum letzten Mal geraucht habe. Ich
schließe daraus, dass nicht jede wahre Aussage
über die Vergangenheit eine unantastbare Wahrheit
ist
Dies ist die zweite
Rekonstruktion, die Sie
auf dem Handout finden können. Die erste Prämisse b0 ist eine
wahre Aussage, die sich ausschließlich auf die Vergangenheit
bezieht. Die zweite Prämisse, jede wahre Aussage, die sich ausschließlich auf die Vergangenheit bezieht, ist eine
unantastbare Wahrheit  scheitern, denn es ist
einfach nicht wahr, dass jede wahre
Aussage über die Vergangenheit
nicht eine unantastbare Wahrheit ist, um zu sehen, warum
zurückrufen  dass laut Fan-in vage
und eine Wahrheit unantastbar ist, nur für den Fall,
dass niemand
etwas gegen ihre Wahrheit tun kann oder jemals konnte, um nur
ein Beispiel zu nennen, betrachten Sie die
Behauptung, dass Cäsar den Rubikon überqueren,
dies ist eine wahre Behauptung,
um die es geht  die vergangenheit, die keine
unantastbare wahrheit ist, denn auch wenn
jetzt niemand etwas dagegen tun kann,
hat sicherlich
irgendjemand etwas dagegen tun können
Aus diesem Grund
sollten wir uns eine andere Rekonstruktion eines inversen Arguments einfallen lassen, das
wir so gut wie möglich auf ihn selbst berufen sollten, schlägt
im obigen Zitat vor, dass p0
eine unantastbare Wahrheit ist, weil p0 eine
wahre Aussage über die
vormenschliche Vergangenheit ist, die zu einer dritten führt
Rekonstruktion einer Böschung erste
Prämisse p0 ist ein wahrer Satz
vollständig über die vormenschliche Vergangenheit zweite
Prämisse jeder wahre Satz
vollständig über die vormenschliche Vergangenheit ist eine
unantastbare Wahrheit, daher ist
Null eine unantastbare Wahrheit. Beachten Sie
jedoch, dass, wenn in Wangs Argumentation
eine Prämisse enthalten ist, die nach sorgfältiger Überlegung
alles andere als offensichtlich erscheinen mag, die Prämisse, dass p0 eine wahre Aussage ist, vollständig
über die Vergangenheit besteht a  Behauptung
, die sich nicht einmal teilweise auf die
Gegenwart oder die Zukunft bezieht, wie sich bald
herausstellen wird, gibt es eine Reihe von
Gründen, diese Annahme abzulehnen
Ich
skizziere drei Argumente für die
Schlussfolgerung, dass p0 keine wahre
Aussage über die Vergangenheit ist, denn
wenn p0 keine wahre Aussage
über die Vergangenheit ist, dann scheint es, dass van in
van uns keinen Grund gegeben hat anzunehmen,
dass p0 eine ist  unantastbare
Wahrheit, da eine vollständige Verteidigung dieser
Argumente im
Rahmen dieses Vortrags unmöglich ist und ich mir
nicht sicher bin, ob ich mich darauf festlegen
möchte  alle Prämissen dieser Argumente auch
wenn vieles dafür spricht ich
habe mich entschieden meine argumente auf
eine ungewöhnliche art und weise zu präsentieren ich werde meine
argumente in form einer liste von
ratschlägen für kompatibilisten präsentieren also komme ich jetzt
zu drei punkt zwei punkt eins  Identität von
notwendigerweise äquivalenten Sätzen Hier
ist mein erster Ratschlag für Kompatibilisten
, eine Theorie von Sätzen zu verteidigen,
nach der notwendigerweise
äquivalente Sätze identisch sind,
zum Beispiel von David Lewis oder Robert
Starling von Kathiria von Satz 4, da
ich argumentieren werde, dass jeder wahre Satz
zumindest teilweise über die Aussage geht  Zukunft, wenn
notwendigerweise äquivalente Sätze
identisch sind, und es ist offensichtlich, dass kein wahrer
Satz vollständig von der Vergangenheit handelt,
wenn jeder wahre Satz zumindest
teilweise von der Zukunft handelt, also kein wahrer
Satz vollständig von der Vergangenheit handelt,
wenn notwendigerweise äquivalente
Sätze identisch sind, habe ich aufgelistet  die wichtigsten
Prinzipien auf dem Handout, die
für die Argumentation entscheidend sind t  Um zu verstehen, warum
dies so ist, nehmen wir an, dass notwendigerweise
äquivalente Aussagen identisch sind. Daraus
folgt direkt, dass
notwendige äquivalente Aussagen
ungefähr zur gleichen Zeit sind. Wenn also P
zumindest teilweise von der Zeit T abhängt und wenn P
notwendigerweise äquivalent zu Q ist, dann ist Q
auch mindestens  teilweise über die Zeit T nehme
zum Beispiel die Aussage, dass
Napoleon die Schlacht von Waterloo verloren hat, und
nehme weiter die notwendigerweise äquivalente
Aussage, dass Napoleon die
Schlacht von Waterloo verloren hat, und zwei plus zwei
gleich vier. Nach dem
Äquivalenzprinzip ist die letztere Aussage
etwa 1815, wenn die  Form ist und umgekehrt.
Weiter ist es plausibel anzunehmen, dass
dies das Konjunktionsprinzip ist. Es ist
plausibel anzunehmen, dass eine
Konjunktion zumindest teilweise von der Zeit T handelt, wenn
sie eine Konjunktion hat, die zumindest teilweise
von MT handelt. Nehmen Sie zum Beispiel den
Satz  dass Newton
1676 den Kalkül erfand und Leibniz
1675 den Kalkül nach dem
Konjunktionsprinzip erfand  Satz
ist ungefähr 1675 Wenn er eine Konjunktion hat,
die ungefähr 1675 ist, nimm endlich den
Satz, dass es morgen entweder eine
Seeschlacht geben wird oder dass es morgen keine
Seeschlacht geben wird. Diese Behauptung
scheint eine notwendige Wahrheit zu sein, die
zumindest teilweise darauf abzielt  die Zukunft jetzt
und jetzt komme ich zum Hauptargument und
Sie können dieses Argument auf dem Handout lesen,
sei P eine willkürliche Wahrheit und
Q die Aussage, dass
es morgen entweder eine Seeschlacht
geben wird oder morgen keine zivile P
beinhaltet Q, vorausgesetzt, dass Q unsere notwendige
Wahrheit ist, vorausgesetzt, dass P beinhaltet, QP ist
äquivalent zur Konjunktion von P und Q
, das ist Frieden, äquivalent zu einer
Aussage, die Q als Konjunktion hat,
aber Q handelt zumindest teilweise von der
Zukunft,
also ist P  äquivalent zu einem Satz
, der eine Konjunktion hat, die sich zumindest
teilweise auf die Zukunft bezieht, folgt aus
dem Konjunktionsprinzip, dass P
äquivalent zu einem Satz ist, der
selbst zumindest teilweise die Zukunft
a betrifft  nd aus dem Äquivalenzprinzip folgt weiter,
dass P selbst
zumindest teilweise von der Zukunft handelt, aber
ohne Zweifel kein Satz, der
selbst zumindest einfach
über die Zukunft ist, vollständig von der
Vergangenheit handelt, daher P nicht vollständig von
der Vergangenheit
handelt, folgt, dass nein  wahrer Satz handelt
ausschließlich von der
Vergangenheit, da Frieden eine willkürliche Wahrheit ist. Ich
folgere daraus, dass kein wahrer Satz
ausschließlich von der Vergangenheit handelt, wenn notwendigerweise
äquivalente Sätze identisch sind, also
lassen Sie uns
gemäß fajn in bangs Argument für
die Unvereinbarkeit des freien Willens einen Schritt zurücktreten und
Determinismus und gemäß einem parallelen
Argument für die Unvereinbarkeit von freiem
Willen und göttlichem Vorherwissen ist p0 eine
unantastbare Wahrheit, wie wir gesehen haben, ist es
höchst plausibel anzunehmen, dass p 0
eine unantastbare Wahrheit ist, wenn p 0 ein wahrer
Satz ist, der ausschließlich über die Prä-  menschliche
Vergangenheit, aber wie wir auch gesehen haben, gibt
es keine wahren Aussagen über
die vormenschliche Vergangenheit, wenn sie notwendigerweise
gleichwertig sind  ent-Aussagen sind identisch,
also
scheint es keinen Grund zu geben, zu glauben, dass p 0
eine unantastbare Wahrheit ist, wenn notwendigerweise äquivalente Aussagen identisch sind. Jetzt komme ich zu 3.2.2
Deskriptivismus über Eigennamen. Hier ist
mein zweiter Rat für Kompatibilisten
, die eine Beschreibungstheorie des Eigennamens verteidigen
benennt unsere Berufung, zu der Sätze
wie Saul Kripke einen berühmten Vortrag
an der University of Princeton hielten und
Sätze wie der Autor von Benennen einer
Notwendigkeit einen berühmten Vortrag an der
University of Princeton
hielten, zum Beispiel Bertrand Russells oder Alvin Plantingas Theory of
Proper  namen die hauptidee einer
beschreibungstheorie von eigennamen ist,
dass eigennamen wie saul
kripke lediglich abkürzungen für eindeutige
beschreibungen wie der autor der
namengebung sind, und notwendigkeit, wie ich argumentieren werde,
folgt aus dieser idee, dass es bei p0 um
alles geht und p0 ist  sicherlich nicht
ganz über die Vergangenheit,
wenn p0 alles ist, um zu sehen, warum eine
Beschreibung t  Theorie der Eigennamen
impliziert, dass es bei p0 nicht ausschließlich um
die Vergangenheit geht.
Erinnern Sie sich daran, dass p0 ein Satz ist,
der den Zustand der Welt zu einer
Zeit lange vor der Existenz des
Menschen ausdrückt
ist ein
Dinosaurier, der auf der Erde wandelt.
Nennen wir diesen Dinosaurier Rex. Betrachten Sie nun das
folgende Beispiel. Angenommen, ich
gehe durch einen Wald und sehe einen
Stein. Ich kann diesen Stein natürlich berühren
, aber ich nehme nicht an, dass wenn ich
Wenn ich diesen Stein berühren würde, würde ich
mit einem sehr alten
subatomaren Teilchen in Kontakt kommen. Ein subatomares Teilchen, das
existiert, seit
Dinosaurier auf der Erde gelebt haben
ist jemals mit Tony in Kontakt gekommen.
Betrachten Sie nun den folgenden Satz. Das einzige
Lebewesen, das jemals mit Tony in Kontakt gekommen ist,
ging bei T
null
auf der Erde  wahre Aussage
, die sich ausschließlich um die
vormenschliche Vergangenheit dreht, da der Drex das einzige
Lebewesen ist, das jemals
mit Tony in Kontakt gekommen ist, hat etwas darüber,
was in der vormenschlichen Vergangenheit passiert ist,
andererseits ist diese Aussage
sicherlich keine unantastbare Wahrheit
Wie angenommen wurde, bin ich in der Lage,
diesen Stein zu berühren, und wenn ich diesen
Stein berühren würde, würde ich mit Tony in Kontakt kommen.
Wenn ich also diesen Stein berühren
würde, wäre es falsch, dass das einzige Lebewesen
, das jemals mit ihm in Kontakt gekommen ist
Tony ging bei T Null auf der Erde, denn es
wäre vorher gewesen, dass es nur ein
Lebewesen gibt, das jemals mit Stein in Kontakt gekommen ist,
daher kann
ich etwas gegen die Tatsache tun, dass das
einzige Lebewesen, das jemals
mit Tony in Kontakt gekommen ist  ging auf der Erde um T
Null Ich schließe daraus, dass dieser Satz dazu
aufruft, eine Aussage auszudrücken, die sich
ausschließlich mit der vormenschlichen Vergangenheit befasst,
obwohl es keine unantastbare Wahrheit ist, so dass
dies meiner Ansicht nach nicht begründet ist  Ein
Gegenbeispiel zu Fan in Versansicht, dass
jede wahre Aussage über
die vormenschliche Vergangenheit eine unantastbare
Wahrheit ist. Sie erinnern sich, dass dies die zweite
Prämisse seiner Argumentation ist.
Dieses Beispiel stellt kein
Gegenbeispiel zu Fan in Banks dar,
da dieser Satz kein a ausdrückt
Behauptung, die sich ausschließlich um die
Vergangenheit dreht, um diesen Hinweis zu sehen, dass dieser
Satz eine eindeutige Beschreibung des einzigen
Lebewesens enthält, das jemals mit Tony in Kontakt gekommen ist,
und dass er daher
dieselbe Behauptung auszudrücken scheint
wie der folgende Satz, da ist
etwas, das ging  Erde bei t0
und das ist so, dass alles
genau dann mit ihr identisch ist, wenn es sich um ein
Lebewesen handelt, das jemals mit Tony in Kontakt gekommen ist
Beschreibungen stellen
kein Gegenbeispiel dar, das sich nach Vances Ansicht von
jeder wahren Aussage völlig
unterscheidet  t die Premium-Vergangenheit ist eine unantastbare
Wahrheit, wenn Sie mir nicht zustimmen, wenn Sie
nicht die Intuition haben, dass diese
Behauptung alles nur um
so schlimmer zum Spaß in Wangs Argumentation ist,
weil wir dann ein direktes
Gegenbeispiel gegen die befürchten müssen  zweite
Prämisse, aber ich glaube nicht. Ich denke, wenn
wir Sätze haben, die eindeutige Beschreibungen enthalten,
drücken diese
Sätze Aussagen aus, die sich auf alles beziehen.
Beachten Sie jedoch, dass gefunden in van jetzt
mit einem Dilemma konfrontiert ist. Dies ist das
Hauptargument dieses Teils, und Sie können  Finden Sie
dieses Argument auf dem Handout, damit Sie es
lesen können, denn gemäß einer
Beschreibungstheorie von Eigennamen ist
der Eigenname Rex lediglich eine
Abkürzung für eine bestimmte Beschreibung.
Nehmen Sie zum Beispiel an, dass Rex lediglich
eine Abkürzung für das einzige Lebewesen
ist, das jemals gekommen ist  in Kontakt mit
Tony entsprechend der Satz Rex ging auf
der Erde um t0 und der Satz das
einzige Lebewesen, das jemals mit Tony in Kontakt gekommen ist,
ging auf der Erde ein  t T
null drückte denselben Satz aus,
jedoch enthält der letztere Satz eine
eindeutige Beschreibung und scheint
daher einen Satz auszudrücken, der
sich auf alles bezieht, da
der letztere Satz denselben
Satz wie
der erstere Satz ausdrückt, scheint der erstere Satz einen
Satz auszudrücken, der ist  über alles jetzt daran
erinnern, dass laut Fan
Indonesien ein wahrer Satz ist, der
den Zustand der Welt zum Zeitpunkt t0 ausdrückt, oder wie
Fan-in Hwang es an anderer Stelle ausdrückt, ein wahrer
Satz, das Zitat gibt eine vollständige
Beschreibung des Zustands der Welt zum
Zeitpunkt t0 und  Zitat nennen wir weiter, dass Rex
bei t0 auf der Erde wandelte, entweder ist die
Aussage, dass Rex bei t0 auf der Erde wandelte,
eine Konjunktion von p0 oder nicht, wenn die
Aussage, dass Wachs bei T 0 auf der Erde wandelte,
keine Konjunktion von p 0 ist, dann p 0
scheint im Gegensatz zu unseren Annahmen keine vollständige
Beschreibung des Zustands der Welt bei
t0 zu sein, wenn
andererseits die Aussage, dass Wachs
t ging  Die Erde bei t0 ist eine Konjunktion von
p 0, dann hat p 0 eine Konjunktion, die
sich um alles dreht
Argument für die Unvereinbarkeit von „
Wir wollen“ und „Göttliches Vorherwissen“.
Um dies zu sehen, sei P die
Aussage, dass es einen Dummkopf geben wird,
der in seinem Herzen sagt, dass das
ontologische Argument ein Fehlschlag sei, und
sei p 0 die Aussage, an die Gott
geglaubt hat  lange vor der Existenz
des ersten Menschen, dass es einen solchen Narren geben wird, dass
nach einer
Beschreibungstheorie der Eigennamen der Eigenname
Gott nur eine Abkürzung für eine
bestimmte Beschreibung ist, nehmen wir zum Beispiel an,
dass Gott nur eine Abkürzung für das ist
, was nichts ist  Größer kann
entsprechend der Satz Gott
glaubt, dass es einen solchen Narren geben wird,
und der Satz, dass dann nichts
Größeres gedacht werden kann, gedacht werden, dass
es einen solchen geben wird  Ein Dummkopf drückte
dieselbe Aussage aus, aber der letztere
Satz enthält eine eindeutige Beschreibung
und scheint eine Aussage auszudrücken
, die sich auf alles bezieht, daher vorausgesetzt,
dass der letztere Satz
dieselbe Aussage wie
der erstere Satz ausdrückt und vorausgesetzt, dass der erstere
Satz p 0 ausdrückt, folgt das  Bei p 0 geht es
um alles,
es ist jedoch offensichtlich, dass kein wahrer
Satz, bei dem es um alles geht,
ausschließlich um die Vergangenheit geht. Daher folgt
aus der Hauptidee einer
Beschreibungstheorie von Eigennamen, dass es bei p 0 nicht
ausschließlich um die Vergangenheit geht, ok, ich überspringe ein
wenig
Bis jetzt habe ich so argumentiert, als hätte ich ein
intuitives Verständnis von Sätzen wie „sich
um die Vergangenheit drehen“ oder „sich ganz um
die Vergangenheit drehen“. Meiner Ansicht nach sind diese Sätze
vollkommen legitim  solange klar ist
, dass wir uns
nur leichtfertig oder locker ausdrücken, aber wenn wir
uns streng oder metaphysisch ausdrücken wollen
Auch wenn wir diese Sätze sozusagen nicht als
selbstverständlich hinnehmen dürfen, werde ich mich bemühen, mich von nun an
streng auszudrücken, und ich werde
daher die beiden Maceo-
Sätze wie
Vergangenheitsein oder Ganzvergangenheit in Frage stellen
Warum ich die Legitimität dieser Sätze in Frage gestellt habe,
ist, dass diese Sätze, wenn sie in bestimmte Sätze eingebettet sind
, Aussagen auszudrücken scheinen,
die implizieren, dass es
hier so etwas wie die
Vergangenheit gibt  gibt es keine
Vergangenheit, denn wenn es keine
Vergangenheit gibt, dann gibt es streng
genommen nichts, von dem
wirklich gesagt werden kann, dass es sich um die
Vergangenheit handelt  Die Vergangenheit Mein
Rat ist natürlich, keine metaphysische
Theorie unserer Berufung zu verteidigen, für die es keine
vergangenen Dinge gibt. Eine Deflation ist
Vergangenheit, wie ich sie nennen werde  Aufmerksam auf die
Ansicht, dass es so etwas wie
Vergangenheit nicht gibt, vielleicht immer noch der Ansicht einen Sinn geben wollen,
dass es Dinge gibt, die einmal
existierten, aber nicht mehr existieren oder die
einmal konkret waren und nicht konkret sind,
zum Beispiel John F. Kennedy der Berlin
Wall Gaius Julius Cäsar das Römische
Reich und deshalb ist mein Rat nur,
eine metaphysische Theorie zu verteidigen,
nach der es kein einzelnes Ding gibt
, das vernünftigerweise Vergangenheit genannt werden könnte,
es gibt keine neurologische Summe oder
Sammlung von allem und nur vergangene Dinge sind
kein großer Container  es was,
das alles und nur vergangene Dinge enthält, denn wie
gesagt, wenn es so etwas wie
Vergangenheit nicht gibt,
dann handelt kein Satz ausschließlich von der Vergangenheit, und wenn kein Satz ausschließlich von
der Vergangenheit handelt, und p0 nicht ausschließlich von
der Vergangenheit oder von den Dreien handelt  Menschliche Vergangenheit Bei einer
Deflation geht es um die Vergangenheit, daher
lehnen wir einfach eine umgekehrte
Annahme ab, dass p0 eine wahre Aussage ist, die sich
ausschließlich auf die vormenschliche Vergangenheit bezieht. Er
wird stattdessen versuchen, einem i einen Sinn zu geben
Indem man diese Annahme durch
eine andere aus seiner Sicht erfolgversprechendere
Annahme ersetzt, stellt sich jedoch heraus, dass
dies schwieriger ist und man
hätte erwarten können, dass ich jetzt nicht versuche,
die Argumentation der Bank so zu rekonstruieren,
dass die Inflation möglicherweise der Vergangenheit angehören
könnte  Akzeptieren Sie dieses Argument, so bietet sich der
folgende Vorschlag an,
eine Aussage betrifft ausschließlich die
vormenschliche Vergangenheit, nur für den Fall, dass es sich
um vergangene Dinge handelt, und nur um vergangene
Dinge, bei denen ein Ding ein vergangenes Ding ist,
nur für den Fall, dass es statisch existierte, bevor
es Menschen gab  Wesen, aber existiert nicht
mehr,
daher könnte gemäß diesem vorgeschlagenen Vorschlag
eine Deflation über die Vergangenheit
in Banks Argument
ungefähr wie folgt rekonstruiert werden, und Sie finden, dass
dies meiner Meinung nach die vierte
Rekonstruktion des Arguments p0 ist eine
wahre Behauptung, die nur ungefähr ist
Dinge, die existierten, bevor es
Menschen gab, die aber nicht mehr existieren,
jeder wahre Satz, der sich
nur auf Dinge bezieht, die existieren  ed, bevor
es Menschen gab, aber nicht
mehr existieren wird, ist eine unantastbare Wahrheit,
daher ist p0 eine unantastbare Wahrheit. Das
Problem bei diesem Vorschlag ist, dass
p0 kein plausibler Kandidat für eine Behauptung zu sein scheint, die
sich nur
auf Dinge bezieht, die vorher existierten
waren irgendwelche Menschen, aber existieren nicht
mehr Nehmen Sie als ersten Schritt das
Argument für die Unvereinbarkeit von
freiem Willen und göttlichem Vorherwissen, es ist offensichtlich, dass es bei p0 um Gott geht, aber es
ist nicht wahr, dass Nietzsche, dass Gott
existierte, bevor es Menschen gab
, aber es gibt  nicht mehr existieren
entweder Gott hat nie existiert oder er
existiert noch,
daher ist p0 keine Behauptung, die sich
nur auf Dinge bezieht, die existierten, bevor
es Menschen gab, aber
nicht existieren, als zweiten Schritt in
Banks Argument für die Unvereinbarkeit
von frei  Wille und Determinismus und erinnern daran,
dass p0 in seinem Argument ein Satz ist
, der den Zustand der Welt zu
einer Zeit ausdrückt, lange bevor es t gab  Der
erste Mensch sei die Zeit und
nehme an, dass zu t0 Dinosaurier Rex
mit dem subatomaren Teilchen Tony in Kontakt kam, und
nehme weiter an, dass Tony noch existiert.
Es scheint Spaß zu machen, uns wieder
mit dem Erwachsenendilemma konfrontiert zu sehen, ob es sich bei p0
um Tony handelt oder nicht  p0 handelt nicht von
Tony, dann scheint P 0 keine
vollständige Beschreibung des Zustands der
Welt zu T 0 zu sein, da
Tonie zu dieser Zeit existiert, wenn andererseits
p0 von Tony handelt,
dann ist p0 keine Aussage, die
nur von Tony handelt  Dinge, die existierten, bevor
es Menschen gab, die aber
für Tony nicht mehr existieren, da
angenommen wurde, dass sie noch existieren. Aus diesem Grund handelt es sich bei einer
Deflation um die Vergangenheit
geht es um vergangene Dinge und
nur um vergangene Dinge, wobei ein Ding
ein vergangenes Ding ist, nur für den Fall, dass es
existierte, bevor es
Menschen gab
.  das ist unabhängig davon, ob es noch
existiert oder nicht
dieser Vorschlag führt ungefähr zu der
folgenden Rekonstruktion dies ist die
fünfte Rekonstruktion auf dem Handzettel
erste Prämisse b0 ist eine wahre Aussage
, die sich nur auf Dinge bezieht, die existierten,
bevor es Menschen gab
zweite Prämisse alle wahr  ein Satz
, der sich nur auf Dinge bezieht, die existierten,
bevor es Menschen gab, ist eine
unantastbare Wahrheit, daher ist p0 eine
unantastbare Wahrheit, allerdings ist nicht
immer klar, ob ein Satz sich
nur auf Dinge bezieht, die existierten, bevor
es Menschen gab,
so stark sie auch sein mögen  Gründe, daran zu zweifeln, dass
jede wahre Aussage, die sich nur
auf Dinge bezieht, die existierten, bevor es
Menschen gab, eine unantastbare
Wahrheit ist, also gab es Grund, diesmal an der
zweiten Prämisse zu zweifeln, zum
Beispiel die Aussage, dass das subatomare
Teilchen Tony noch
Tausende von Menschen leben wird  Jahre, wenn es
Aussagen gibt, die sich nur auf Dinge
beziehen, die existierten  Bevor es Menschen gab
, scheint diese Behauptung ein
plausibler Kandidat zu sein, denn diese Behauptung
scheint sich nur auf ein subatomares
Teilchen zu beziehen, das existierte, bevor es
Menschen gab, aber nehmen Sie an, dass der
arme alte Tony von verrückten
Wissenschaftlern des Large Hadron Collider gefangen genommen wurde
und nehmen Sie weiter an, dass einer dieser
Wissenschaftler in der Lage ist, etwas zu tun, das
den armen alten Tony zerstören könnte, selbst
wenn Tony tatsächlich noch
Tausende von Jahren leben wird, ist es keine
unantastbare Wahrheit, dass Tony
dafür weitere Tausende von Jahren leben wird
ist jemand, der etwas
gegen
die Tatsache tun kann, dass Tony noch
Tausende von Jahren leben wird, also schließe ich, dass
die zweite Prämisse oder es Grund zu der Annahme gibt
, dass die zweite Prämisse im Allgemeinen falsch ist, folgere
ich, dass es
schwieriger ist als erwartet  Sinnvoll ist
ein Vorab-Argument zumindest, wenn
es so etwas nicht gibt, aber ich
hoffe, dass unsere Reflexionen über die Vergangenheit
wird den Boden für ein weiteres
Argument bereiten, das nicht einmal für diejenigen akzeptiert wird,
die glauben, dass es
so etwas wie die Vergangenheit
gibt
Das letzte Argument ist also für
Sie und Sie finden das ganze Argument auf
dem Handzettel für eine vergangene Sache, wie wir
gesehen haben, entweder eine Sache, die einmal
existierte, aber nicht mehr existiert, oder
andererseits eine Sache, die einmal existierte,
unabhängig davon ob  es ist Alexis
oder nicht so im Allgemeinen Spaß in Van
scheint sich dem folgenden Dilemma zu stellen
, das das Hauptargument dafür ist, dass
andere Dinge, die einmal existierten und immer noch
existieren, wenn ich mich so ausdrücken darf,
Teil der Vergangenheit sind oder nicht, ob Dinge, die
einmal existierten und  immer noch existieren, sind nicht
Teil der Vergangenheit, dann gibt es Grund zu
der Annahme, dass p0 entweder keine vollständige
Beschreibung des vergangenen Zustands der
Welt ist oder sich nicht vollständig auf die Vergangenheit
bezieht, denn entweder handelt es sich bei p0 um Dinge, die einmal
existierten, und  noch existiert oder nicht,
wenn es bei p0 nicht um Dinge geht, die einmal
existierten, dann ist p0 keine
vollständige Beschreibung eines
vergangenen Welthaupts, wenn sich andererseits p0
um Dinge handelt, die einmal existierten und immer noch
existieren, dann ist p0 nicht vollständig  über die
Vergangenheit, denn dann geht es bei p0 um Dinge,
die nicht Teil der Vergangenheit sind. Wenn man
andererseits denkt, dass es einmal existierte und immer noch
existiert, ist es Teil der Vergangenheit, dann
gibt es wiederum Grund zu bezweifeln, dass jede wahre
Aussage, die sich ausschließlich auf die Vergangenheit bezieht,
eine ist  unantastbare Wahrheit, denn dann gibt es
zwei Aussagen, die sich ausschließlich auf
die Vergangenheit
beziehen, obwohl sie sich auf Dinge beziehen, die
noch existieren, und wenn es wahre Aussagen gibt, die sich
ausschließlich auf die Vergangenheit
beziehen, die viele Dinge sind, die noch
existieren, gibt es keinen Grund, dies zu
glauben  Jede wahre Behauptung, die sich ausschließlich
auf die bezieht, geht nur über Dinge,
die außerhalb unserer Kontrolle liegen, weil diese
Dinge immer noch existieren, und zwar in jedem Fall, was in
Bangs Argument für seine Annahme ist, dass
p0 ein Unberührter ist  Wenn die Wahrheit
fehlschlägt, hat er uns keinen Grund gegeben, oder
es gibt zumindest
Grund zu der Annahme, dass er uns keinen Grund gegeben hat zu glauben,
dass p0 eine unantastbare Wahrheit ist, also ist es
nach dem Zitat von Fontaine Wagon
Freewill ein Rätsel, weil
es Gute gibt  Argumente für die
Unvereinbarkeit von Willensfreiheit und
Determinismus und gute Argumente für die
Indeterminismus, und niemand hat
jemals einen sehr plausiblen Kandidaten
für den Fehler in einem der Argumente in
beiden Klassen identifiziert und zitiert, schließt er mit
einem Zitat über Angelegenheiten
in Bezug auf den Determinismus des freien Willens moralische
Verantwortung, die uns offensichtlich wahr zu sein scheint,
ist ein falsches
Ende Zitat In meinem Vortrag habe ich versucht
, einen Fehler in der Front-Enviros-
Argumentation zu identifizieren oder wofür etwas
ein Fehler sein könnte, da wir den einzigen
Grund zu der Annahme gesehen haben  Dass p0 eine
unberührbare Wahrheit ist, ist die Annahme, dass
p0 eine wahre Aussage ist, die sich ausschließlich auf die Vergangenheit bezieht. Das
ist der einzige Grund, warum wir so sein müssen
Angenommen, diese Aussage ist
unantastbar,
aber wie wir auch gesehen haben, gibt es
einige Gründe, an der Annahme zu zweifeln,
dass p0 eine wahre Aussage ist, die sich
ausschließlich auf die Vergangenheit bezieht. Ich habe argumentiert,
dass p0 keine wahre Aussage ist, die sich
ausschließlich auf die Vergangenheit bezieht, wenn notwendigerweise
äquivalente Aussagen  identisch sind, wenn
Eigennamen Abkürzungen für
eindeutige Beschreibungen sind und wenn es keine
Vergangenheit gibt, schließlich habe ich
argumentiert, dass es unabhängige
Gründe gibt zu glauben, dass eine Beschreibung eines
vergangenen Zustands des Wortes wie p0 entweder
nicht unantastbar ist oder nur  komplett, wenn auch nicht
ganz über die Vergangenheit, das heißt, ich habe
argumentiert, dass es unabhängige
Gründe gibt zu glauben, dass p0 entweder nicht
unantastbar ist oder sich nicht ganz um die
Vergangenheit dreht,
und als logische Folge habe ich gezeigt, dass so
ziemlich die gleiche Argumentation
für berühmte Argumente gilt  für die
inkompatibilität von wir werden ende göttliche
vorahnung danke